experimental self-driving vehicles
are taking to our streets skies and seas
powered by artificial intelligence they
might transport you around cities
grow your food or deliver packages to
your doorstep
they could reveal hidden glimpses of the
world around you
and even save lives
they are designed to outperform humans
at specialized tasks
in very specific environments but they
are not quite ready
to take full control training their ai
to interact safely with us in our
complex and unpredictable world
is still a significant challenge
deciding how and whether they should be
used
is another
[Music]
self-driving vehicles use sensors and
artificial intelligence
or ai ai is what enables self-driving
vehicles to react
in unpredictable situations this
is an early example of british
self-driving technology
the car was modified by the road
research laboratory
which added an experimental automatic
steering system
the experiments were carried out on a
specially adapted test track
when the automatic steering mode was
engaged the driver could take their
hands
off the wheel this car was a prototype
and was never commercially produced at
the time
researchers estimated such systems could
allow 50
more cars to drive on the roads while
reducing
accident rates today
pods are being used to help carry
passengers through
airports and car parks this is an
example that researchers are testing in
greenwich
where it could soon take visitors on a
scenic journey around the peninsula
quiet and fully electric it's meant to
operate in public spaces
alongside pedestrians cyclists and
animals
self-driving technology is being
developed for many types of land
vehicles
from cars and trucks to military supply
vehicles
and robots that make deliveries
and farm crops tom is the first
prototype developed by the small robot
company
it can decide what route to take around
a field photograph crops
and tag their position on a map it works
alongside
dick and harry which pull weeds and
water the crops
this data is sent to an artificial
intelligence driven control system
called wilma
technology developers argue self-driving
vehicles could make journeys
faster safer and more sustainable but
some environments such as busy cities
are highly unpredictable
and would need significant modifications
to enable self-driving technology
your behavior might have to change too
remote-controlled drones piloted by
human operators
have been around for decades now
experimental drones that fly themselves
are taking to the skies
programming drones to fly on their own
allows human operators to use
many at a time and send them where
humans cannot go
as young boys in afghanistan brothers
masood and mahmoud hassani
would make and race wind powered toys
today their goal is to create an
unmanned
demining system that could clear the
world's landmines
within 10 years massoud first created
the mine caffon ball
in 2011 roughly the height and weight of
a person
the full-sized art piece catches enough
wind
to roll it over minefields detonating
hidden landmines as it goes
many types of self-driving water
vehicles are in development
from small ships that form footbridges
on demand
to massive cargo ships and military
vessels that hunt
for hidden submarines
some are being developed to explore
challenging deep ocean
environments and beneath sea ice in
polar regions
in these extreme places far beyond the
limits of human endurance and
communication
researchers must rely on these vehicles
to take
full control over their missions
we know more about the surface of mars
than our ocean floor
these technologies could help make our
world a smaller place
they might also help us protect it
this is a two-thirds scale model of the
auto sub
long-range vehicles engineers at the
national oceanography center
have developed the alr fleet to explore
the deep ocean
and beneath polar ice collecting data
on the causes and impacts of climate
change
each alr is equipped with intelligent
navigation systems
to ensure they can operate independently
for months at a time
up to six thousand metres under water
and two thousand kilometers away
before returning safely with valuable
data driverless cars
have been a dream for decades but until
now
have been mostly science fiction this
technology
is developing quickly and in the coming
years we will increasingly see
driverless cars and drones in our public
spaces
when that happens we will all have
decisions to make
about how we think these vehicles should
be used
and all of this will raise the question
who
is in control